after a bunch of very unsuccessful
Terminator movies is it time for a
reboot and are there active discussions
already taking place welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
yeah it's fair to say dark fate failed
quite badly an interview recently James
Cameron said that he thought it failed
basically because you know you could get
away with having Linda Hamilton in her
60s to return you could get away with
Arnold Schwarzenegger in his 70s but you
can't do both because it's not your
Terminator anymore it's not your dad's
Terminator it becomes your grandad's
Terminator and he felt that that just
didn't work
a lot of fans myself included didn't
really understand why they killed John
Connor almost immediately but there are
lots of other problems with that movie
and to be honest there's been lots of
problems with lots of Terminator movies
for quite a while
Sarah's my mother Kyle
and you're my father
so in an interview recently James
Cameron was asked what he felt about
sort of artificial intelligence and
things listen he started talking about
Terminator he then just happened to very
nonchalantly like it was nothing
happened to mention that there are
actually active discussions going on
right now about a return of the
franchise and not just a return but a
hard reboot I don't know why you cry so
what does this mean well
this is an iconic character it's an
iconic Universe it is actually probably
more relevant today than it ever has
been with stories like Elon musk's
project to actually develop technology
that can connect directly to the brain I
mean this really is like the early
stages of Skynet I mean that's taking
artificial intelligence and actually
throwing in a bit of human control it's
like Skynet and you know like the Matrix
just sort of like did that but
the technology and actual interface with
technology today is even more relevant
now than it was in the 80s back when
there weren't even cell phones
so
I actually think determinator universe
as a whole is something that should be
explored more but
it had to be a hard reboot if they're
going to bring back any more movies for
one it can't be Arnold Schwarzenegger
anymore God love him it's been done
I'll be back
I'll be back what it actually needs a
hard rebooting as well because the
technology that's actually possible
today has kind of overtaken the universe
that was set up back in the 80s
so I actually think a hard reboot of the
Terminator franchise could be worth
doing but for me
I don't mind a reboot I don't mind a
sequel I hate prequels as you know if
you're a regular side tracker I think
they are a nightmare
but
in this case Terminator to be honest it
doesn't need a reboot or a new movie or
a sequel it needs a reimagining what
they need to do is take the Nugget of
the idea
and just redo it into a new film a new
project you can call it the Terminator
could terminate a universe Terminator
whatever you like because that's just a
name but to be honest it needs to try to
get away from the original franchise as
much as possible I need your clothes
your boots and your motorcycle
if you can't really do that if you call
it Terminator you're always going to
compare it to the Terminator 2 movie
aren't you or the original
but the actual story I actually think is
worth telling again and if somebody
comes up with an interesting story that
James Cameron can get his teeth into and
develop something that is up to date
relevant to up-to-date's technology and
up to date with the relevant world we
live in then I can actually see why they
would do this
do I want them to do it
very cool music from the original movie
a very cool characters if it was done in
a different way then maybe
um but to be honest I would say don't
bother
we don't need a reboot we don't need
another sequel of this movie you can go
and watch the original go and actually
watch the special effects from
Terminator 2. remembering how old that
movie is now they still stand up
that is still an excellent film it is
still excellent cinema James Cameron
knows his stuff when it comes to these
things and he basically made a film that
is timeless
why would you want to mess to that any
more than you need to we don't need a
new Terminator movie I can understand
having a movie along those lines a
reimagined movie but don't call it
Terminator
come with me if you want to live
so there are active talks we are
probably going to get a hard reboot of
the Terminator franchise and I gotta say
we shouldn't but it's gonna happen
anyway I just hope it doesn't lose quite
as much money as dark fainted because
Paramount currently can't afford to lose
another 120 million dollars on a
Terminator movie
but guys get in the comments tell me
exactly what you think about this news
is a terminated franchise something that
should be rebooted as it still got some
legs and actually do you just want to
see a series of movies that are much
much better than some of the sequels
we've had since T2
actually also isn't it funny that
Terminator Terminator 2 is one of the
very rare occasions actually where a
sequel is better than the original and
then they've gone on to make such an
absolute [ __ ] show of SQL since
coincidence irony I'm not really sure
but anyway get in the comments and tell
me exactly what you think or like I say
do you follow me and think that no leave
it alone
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and if
you enjoy the content please consider
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
and hitting the join Button as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]